welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and he now locked
into the channel where we break down all
the latest movies new game releases TV
shows and comic books this episode will
be going to a galaxy far far away to
talk about one of the Mandalorians most
fascinating characters korra june
throughout this video i'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the character including her
backstory and the best fan theory on
what could be going on with her there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't had a chance to watch the first
four episodes of the Mandalorian and
don't want to know what happens then
McConkey that that means this is the end
for you and start never mind without the
way I just want to give a huge thank you
for clicking this video now let's get
into our breakdown of Korra June okay so
mondo and baby Yoda come across Korra
June on the planet of Soren man now
notices her giving him those come to the
dark side eyes and he decides to follow
her using Batman's detective vision to
track her down Korra gets the drop on
him and shows that she's more than a
match for the character this is a guy
who's taken blaster bolts to the head
but one punch from the femme fatale
knocks him down faster than the
Emperor's approval rating after order 66
thanks to the calming mood of baby Yoda
the two decide that talking it out is
the best way to go and we learn that
Korra was a shock trooper that was part
of the Rebel Alliance who was tasked
with hunting down Imperial warlords
after the events of the Battle of Endor
Korra was so dedicated to the cause that
she even got a Rebel Alliance symbol
tattooed on her face and know this is a
little hard to make out in the episode
in behind the scenes shots and the toys
for the series this is clearly visible
after the destruction of the Death Star
to : bigger is better the galaxy became
slightly destabilized and this may have
helped with the formation of the first
order which I'll get into in just a bit
when discussing her past Korra says the
following so most of my action mopping
up after end or mostly X Imperial
warlords they wanted it fast and quiet
they'd send us in on the drop ships no
support just us
then when the MS were gone and the
politics started we will a peacekeeper
protecting delegates suppressing riots
not what I signed up for this lets us
know that after most of the remnants of
the empire were dead that the alliance
decided to become more politically
organized and this may have led to
negative consequences before Disney
wiped the slate clean with the expanded
universe the New Republic was constantly
built up and torn down all the way
through the Canon up until the events of
Star Wars dark empire in which it
settled down and found stability
juxtaposing this we know from the force
awakens and sequel trilogy that in the
new Canon the Republic wasn't really
that effective at all and this is why
the Empire in some form or another has
risen once more it's likely that the
best soldiers of the rebellion ended up
becoming bored with the way things were
going and due to this they let their
positions
thus lesser leaders were allowed to rule
things their way and they didn't quite
have a grip on what was going on we know
that Luke ended up leaving and cutting
himself off from the force I know this
may have massively been down to kylo Ren
I definitely think that the Republic
could have also been instrumental in
this decision Leia herself is also
clearly working outside of the Republic
and this may be due to the fact that she
couldn't get on with the bureaucracy
that was prevalent within it with no
more Jedi Knights and the leaders
soldiers and major parts of the army
that made it what it is either
ostracized or retired it's easy to see
how people became disenfranchised across
the galaxy and thus the first order was
able to rise once more we have seen
throughout the Star Wars saga that the
government twists and changes are some
of the big reasons for its collapse and
this is exemplified in the prequel
trilogy in which the Senate falls apart
and is taken over by the Sith Lord Darth
Sidious due to how easily manipulated
and corrupt it is either way cara saw
this fall coming and decided to dive out
of the conflict and move to so again
though she still clearly believes that
the empire may be out there and keeps an
eye out for bounty hunters at all times
actually found a lot of similarities
between Cara's position and the real
world Nazi hunters that existed after
the Second World War there were a lot of
forces namely Jewish ones that made it
their mission to track down surviving
members of the Reich and they'll magneto
kinda played of this role in x-men first
class is actually a lot of interesting
aspects of our own history that you
should definitely check out if you want
to see some similarities between Cara
and real
figures anyway after divulging most of
her past at the mandalorian she insists
that they have to leave the planet as
she found at first but it's not long
until they are back on each other's
paths when Mandel hires her to help with
the rescue of a fishing village on the
planet
this shows that though Korra is out of
combat when it comes to fighting evil
that she still operates as a mercenary
from time to time when scouting outside
of the village Korra and mono discovered
the huge tract prints of an 80s Dee and
they later returned to the village
training the population to be ready for
their counter-attack after digging a
trench
she and mando sneak into the Raiders
base destroying their favorite tent and
leading the ATS Dee back to the village
which they then destroy Korra is pretty
much the MVP of the battle rushing the
huge lurking machine and using herself
as bait to draw it out so that mono can
easily destroy it with a detonator
this forces the remaining clan Union
Raiders to flee and the villages settle
going back to their peaceful way of life
June suggested that mannose stay in the
village in about a peaceful life but he
states that the attack will draw a lot
of attention though he decides to leave
baby Yoda there in order for it to have
a normal childhood however on the
outskirts of the settlement Jun
discovers a bounty hunter which he kills
before it can assassinate baby Oda and
as we know we must protect baby Ola at
all costs this lets us know that bounty
hunters will be constantly coming for
the two characters no matter what and it
kind of leads us into a fan theory on
what could be happening down the line
with Korra okay so we know that no
matter where mondo and baby Oda hide
they will never be safe it doesn't
matter if they're on the metropolis of
Corus aunt or a backwater planet likes
organ the hunters will keep coming for
baby Yoda like a grandma constantly
visiting the toy section in the run-up
to Christmas hoping that Disney have
finally made the one thing that could
make or break their grandchild holiday
this yeah please just get them out in
time this pretty much means that no
matter what mando and Yoda are gonna
have to tackle the problem head-on and
take the fight back to the Empire
personally I think that throughout the
next couple of episodes that Manor will
be building a network of mercenaries
that he will eventually use to storm the
client and those that have a bounty out
on baby odors head the synopsis for
Episode five reads the Mandalorian helps
a rookie bounty hunter who is in over
his
and to me this definitely adds a lot of
weight to the fact that mando is going
to be getting contacts together from
people across the galaxy by the time
he's got enough for a whatsapp group I
can see him storming the headquarters of
the client and the guild in order to
stop them but once and for all we know
that the Mandalorians are on Team baby
ara and that Cara definitely is too and
though she may have been trying to avoid
as many fights as possible due to her
retirement I can just see the mention of
an ex Imperial warlords such as the
client being enough to draw her out
we know that lack of targets like this
was a big reason for her retirement so
getting rid of one more will definitely
be enough enticer in my opinion mando
will likely need as much help as he can
get as well as we know that there are a
lot of bounty hunters after him and baby
Oda including I g11 who may be a little
angry that mano shot him in the head at
the end of the first episode this isn't
the case and I can definitely see it
being a nest egg for the show going
forward when promoting his film knives
out Rian Johnson accidentally let it
slip that he had seen baby Oda on set a
couple of weeks prior and now we're all
jealous of him getting to meet the
little guy face to face it also
highlights that a second season of the
Mandalorian is currently in development
the Mandalorian season Wan would have
finished filming months and months ago
so the fact that he came face to face
with their very recently unset does
cement that things are going ahead with
its next installment I guess we will see
what happens but you can definitely
count on mando and Korra's Pat's
crossing again as even the two
characters believe that so yeah that's
my theory I have spoken now we'll be
Slee and love to hear your thoughts on
Korra and what you think will happen
with the character in the future comment
below and let me know and if you enjoy
this video and think this is the way
then please give it a thumbs up and make
sure you check out my full breakdown of
baby Yoda which would be linked at the
end we go over everything you need to
know about the cutest critter in the
galaxy and what could be going on with
the Empire's plan for it we also do
weekly breakdowns of the Mandalorian and
we went through the series episode by
episode to point out everything you
missed all the Easter eggs and where the
plot could be going in the future
I'll leave that link at the end and if
you want to come chat to me after the
video then make sure you follow me on
Twitter
definition YT will head over to my
discord server which should be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free adjoining we have
an awesome community so hopefully I see
over there very soon we're also giving
away a free copy of the marble phase 3
part 2 box on blu-ray which contains
Black Panther infinity war and Game
Captain Marvel them all and all you have
to do to be in with the chance of
winning is like the video make sure that
you subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on Korra tune in the
comments section below when it's gonna
be chosen on the 15th of December and
the set will be shipped out from the n2
if I get surprised it's the best of luck
to everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]